a new study has come out confirming what
I certainly know which is that having a
pet can actually make you healthier
we've got some info for you this from
the Washington Post the human animal
bond research initiative foundation that
is a lot of words they recently found
evidence that human animal interactions
could lift mood reduce stress and
anxiety perhaps by activating the
hormone oxytocin now as a dog lover I've
talked about a lot my dog has brought a
tremendous amount of joy to my life I
see this all the time with people that
love animals and adopt animals and I'm
not surprised by any of this so
sometimes it's nice when when science
confirms some [ __ ] that you know I
thought that was I thought that had been
confirmed but but their double confirm
ragatha they just going back there
they're updating their conversation but
they need time to do my dog saved my
life all day every day I mean literally
they saved my life just again keeping
your spirits up giving me that the love
that no other creature gives me
accepting the love in a way that no
other creature accepts it well it's just
that it's that unconditional part of my
day I mean I just love it and I think
it's terrible for my daughter for a
husband all right here's there's no
there's no strife if my dog is looking
at me and thinking I'm an [ __ ] he
doesn't say it so I can't you know
there's no there's no conf oh yeah well
I always think it's funny when people
talk about like having kids and they're
always like yeah well you know it's a
lot of work and your life changes and
that and not to say it's not rewarding
but there's always that they we start
with that yeah yeah but when someone has
a dog or you meet demoted oh my god this
is the best I this don't change my love
enjoy yeah correct me if I'm wrong I
think you might be a cat guy oh yeah
absolutely you are you know sick twisted
you know I think a long time ago I made
a comment about like setting a cat on
fire and that's like the number one
thing that I still get like hate about
on Twitter so you don't have ki never
actually set a count on fire for the
record and I would have never done that
I don't hate cats it's just funny to
hate cats so like I go for that so you
don't have a cat I don't know why I said
Oh cat person at all my god I love dogs
you're kidding me yeah I just told a
story about shooting a cat with a BB gun
earlier oh that was earlier good we'll
add a great back of that yeah you have
to um I have dogs and I love dogs and
and totally makes perfect sense and I
think any place where you have a work
situation where you can bring in your
dog i think it just increases overall
productivity of course that's not
scientific that I know of I bet you
there maybe it does but but I I just
think that it's such a nice addition to
my god I wish I had my phone and I would
show you my little boys yeah so alright
so we're all we're all agreed on the dog
thing but now let's talk about cats for
a second because every time I do let's
talk about cakes could give you the
Logan I eat all your major thanks no but
really let's talk about cats for a
second because I don't like cats I'm
allergic to cats I've had family members
with tats that have tried to attack me
my dog and a cat got into a big fight
once my dog left bleeding so I don't
know I don't like cats but I know people
love cat right so I don't want to just
attack yeah community now even though
they're all nuts we all know that right
Gabi more fire there's the internet or
under section I know I know look I have
I know people that I love and respect
who have these sweet cats and I'm just
not attracted to them yeah the big
problem I have with cats is that they'll
be really nice and doing it and then
they counts right it's like there's like
no reason like you there's no trust
right and so the cat people the cat
people always say well if you dog people
there's a you dog people it's because
you're so needy and you need that
affection constantly I'm a cat person
I'm self-aware and I just want an animal
that stairs and judges me all the time I
guess it's something like that I don't
although they've also proven the cat
feces like releases some toxin that
makes people crazy right explains the
collie Catwoman yes state okay I trust
trying to be nice to the cat people to
wrap us up with you I mean I think
you've pretty much said it all cat
people are weird you know i'll give it
but I know somebody who has like 16 cats
she loves them yeah certainly she
doesn't get out my station no she does
she gets a la petite and Jules has two
dogs to dog those poor dogs anyway cat
people you know I'm trying I'm trying
here tell us why you love cats I want to
know and dog people I know why you love
your dog so you but feel free to comment
right elbow
you